Muchos nos habéis pedido que hagamos este
vídeo.
Este vídeo es una actualización de uno que
subimos hace varios años y que tuvimos que
eliminar por problemas técnicos.
Así que hemos revisado el guión, hemos actualizado
los datos y ahora os lo volvemos a presentar
¿Por qué Países Bajos es la mayor potencia
agrícola del mundo?
Ahora mismo os lo vamos a contar.
Os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale buscarlo
en Google ¿Cuál es la mayor potencia agrícola
de Europa?
Muchos pensaréis en España, Italia, o tal
vez Francia.
A fin de cuentas, son países con buen clima
y con miles de hectáreas de tierra cultivable.
Sin embargo, ninguno de estos países le llega
a la suela del zapato a los PAÍSES BAJOS,
también conocido como HOLANDA.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Holanda es el
mayor exportador de alimentos del mundo, sólo
superado por Estados Unidos.
¿Qué decís?
¿Qué no estáis sorprendidos?
Pues pensadlo bien.
Hablamos de un país tan pequeño, que incluso
tuvieron que construir diques para ganarle
terreno al mar.
De hecho, es uno de los países con más densidad
de población del mundo.
Es decir, que apenas hay terreno disponible
para cultivar.
A eso hay que sumarle que son uno de los países
más ricos y más modernos del mundo.
El primer mercado de valores que se creó
en la historia fue la bolsa de Ámsterdam.
Y seguro que todos conocéis empresas holandesas
como la SHELL, PHILIPS o el banco ING.
Normalmente, cuando un país tiene muchas
empresas de industria o servicios, la agricultura
pasa a un segundo plano.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué?
Pues imaginad que tenemos un terreno, por
ejemplo en España, que mide una hectárea.
Si lo dedicamos a plantar patatas, podemos
ganar entre unos 7000 y 8000 euros por hectárea.
Ahora bien, imaginad la cantidad de dinero
que no se puede ganar si utilizamos esa superficie
para construir una fábrica o un edificio
de oficinas ¿Entendéis ahora a lo que me
refiero?
Pues bien, pese a todo esto, Holanda es el
líder mundial en exportación de patatas.
Por encima de Francia, España o, incluso
Estados Unidos.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
¿Agricultura en Europa?
¡Seguro que hay subvenciones de Bruselas
por algún sitio!
La agricultura es uno de los sectores más
protegidos y que más ayudas tiene en toda
la Unión Europea.
Sin embargo, Países Bajos no es, ni muchísimo
menos, el país que más dinero recibe.
Por supuesto, tienen sus ayudas como todos
los demás países miembros.
Pero no llegan ni a la tercera parte de lo
que le pagan a Grecia, por ejemplo.
Y si lo comparamos con otros países más
grandes como Francia, las diferencias son
abismales.
Así que ¿Cómo es posible que con tan poco
terreno y tan pocas ayudas, Holanda haya llegado
a ser el huerto del mundo?
Como os podéis imaginar, la respuesta es
tan sencilla como una palabra: TECNOLOGÍA.
En una granja de Países Bajos nos podemos
encontrar tractores que se conducen solos,
drones que monitorizan los cultivos y, por
supuesto, optimización de recursos al más
alto nivel.
Sin embargo, todavía queda una pregunta ¿Por
qué Holanda tiene más moderna que, por ejemplo,
España, que tiene más ayudas de Europa?
¿Qué han hecho en los Países Bajos que
se pueda imitar en otros países?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
DEL CAMPO A LA UNIVERSIDAD
En los años 70, Holanda era una de las economías
más prósperas de Europa.
Empresas como Philips o Airbus estaban conquistando
los mercados internacionales.
Y todo esto son buenas noticias.
Pero, como siempre decimos en VisualPolitik,
no todo es tan bonito.
Imaginad que tenéis 20 años y vivís en
Países Bajos en esa época ¿Dónde querríais
trabajar?
¿En una empresa internacional como Philips,
con unos sueldos altos y buenas condiciones…
o en la granja de vuestro padre?
¡Exacto!
La agricultura holandesa estaba al borde de
la desaparición.
A esto hay que sumarle otra cosa muy importante.
Como os decíamos antes, Países Bajos es
muy pequeño y apenas hay espacio para grandes
explotaciones agrarias.
Por ejemplo, en Estados Unidos hay terreno
de sobra.
Y eso significa que los agricultores se pueden
agrupar y crear grandes explotaciones.
De hecho, a día de hoy, buena parte de las
granjas estadounidenses pertenecen a grandes
empresas.
Eso significa que pueden hacer inversiones
de escala y, por ejemplo, comprar una avioneta
para fumigar grandes extensiones de tierra.
Sin embargo, en el caso de Países Bajos,
las granjas son pequeñas.
El tamaño medio era, y es, de alrededor de
7 hectáreas.
Y con cultivos tan pequeños, es muy complicado
hacer grandes inversiones.
Para colmo, para los años 70, los sueldos
de los holandeses ya eran mucho más altos
que la de otros países europeos.
En otras palabras, que a diferencia de los
agricultores del Sur de Italia, los holandeses
no podían competir con precios bajos.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Y por qué necesitaban
agricultura?
A fin de cuentas, por aquellos años, ya existía
cierta idea de mercado internacional.
Países Bajos podía dedicarse a importar
la comida mientras ellos se dedicaban a fabricar
televisiones o aviones ¿Verdad?
Pues sí, tenéis razón.
Desde el punto de vista puramente económico,
podrían haber prescindido de su sector primario
sin problemas.
Pero, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
no todo es economía en esta vida.
Y en un país como Holanda, las asociaciones
de campesinos tienen mucho poder.
Más que en casi cualquier otro país.
Por ejemplo, los que veáis este vídeo desde
España habréis oído hablar de la Mesa del
diálogo social ¿Verdad?
Se trata de un organismo en el que se reúnen
el gobierno, la patronal y los sindicatos.
Pues bien, en Países Bajos tienen alto parecido.
Pero junto a la patronal y los sindicatos,
también están representadas las asociaciones
de agricultores y ganaderos.
Y, en los años 70, los agricultores y ganaderos
holandeses no estaban dispuestos a cambiar
de trabajo.
Así que, poneros en situación: Holanda tenía
que mantener su sector primario a toda costa.
Pero, a la vez, todas las condiciones estaban
en su contra.
Llegados a este punto, ya sé lo que estáis
pensando… ¡Subvenciones!
¡La solución es dar subvenciones a los agricultores
para que dejen de protestar!
¿verdad?
Desde luego, no sería ni la primera ni la
última vez que se aplican este tipo de políticas.
Pero el gobierno de Holanda tenía otros planes.
Ya puestos a tener que mantener al sector
primario, querían a hacerlo bien.
Y, como no podían reducir los sueldos ni
agrupar las granjas, sólo quedaba una solución:
mejorar la productividad.
Es decir, que un mismo granjero produzca más
y mejor trabajando el mismo tiempo ¿Y cómo
se consigue esto?
¡Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver!
LA UNIVERSIDAD DE WAGENINGEN
Seguro que lo habéis oído mil veces: Silicon
Valley no sería lo que es hoy en día si
no fuera por la Universidad de Standford.
Se trata de la meca de la investigación en
todo lo que tenga que ver con electrónica
y telecomunicaciones ¡Pero no sólo se dedican
a investigar!
También forman a los informáticos mejor
preparados del mundo.
Y según salen de la universidad, van directamente
a trabajar a esas grandes empresas como GOOGLE,
APPLE o TESLA.
Pues bien, en lo que agricultura se refiere,
la meca de la innovación no está en EEUU
sino en Holanda.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, estoy hablando
de la Universidad de Wageningen, también
conocida como el FOOD VALLEY.
Probablemente muchos de vosotros no hayáis
oído hablar nunca de esta universidad.
Esto se debe a que se limitan a trabajar en
el mundo de la agricultura.
No tienen titulaciones de derecho ni de historia
del arte.
El lema de Wageningen es mejorar la calidad
alimentaria del mundo entero.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero qué tiene esta
universidad que no tenga, por ejemplo, la
Politécnica de Madrid o la Universidad de
Chile?
De entrada, la primera diferencia es el dinero.
Países Bajos sabía que necesitaba tecnología
para mejorar su campo.
Así que ¿Qué hicieron?
Cubrir a sus científicos de dinero.
En sólo dos décadas, el presupuesto para
investigación de la Universidad de Wageningen
se multiplicó por dos ¡Pero esperad un momento
porque el dinero no es lo único importante!
En realidad, lo más importante no es el CUANTO
sino el DE DÓNDE venía ese dinero.
Veréis… tanto en España como en casi toda
Latino América, hay una línea muy clara
que separa la Universidad pública de la privada.
Las universidades públicas viven del Estado.
Punto.
Por supuesto que pueden tener algún tipo
de colaboración con la empresa privada.
Pero… seamos honestos, a duras penas llega
a representar un mínimo porcentaje de la
financiación total.
El caso de Wageningen es distinto.
Su modelo de financiación consiste en que
el 50% del dinero lo pone el Gobierno, el
25% viene de los propios ingresos de la universidad
y el último 25% viene de las empresas privadas.
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
¿Empresas privadas financiando la universidad?
¿Significa esto que la universidad es privada?
¡Por supuesto que no!
Pero tiene una gran ventaja.
Permite que la universidad esté conectada
al resto de la sociedad.
¡Vale!
Perdonad, esto ha sonado a chorrada de político.
Lo siento.
Os lo explico con un ejemplo.
Para preparar este vídeo hablé con varios
ganaderos de España, concretamente de las
Islas Canarias, para que me explicara cómo
funciona la modernización agrícola.
Seguramente no lo sepáis pero la ganadería
en Canarias es muy importante.
Sobretodo la caprina.
Tienen un tipo específico de cabra, la llamada
CABRA PALMERA que es única en el mundo.
Y, lógicamente, hay varios institutos y fundaciones
que se dedican a estudiar a este tipo de cabras.
Sin embargo, prácticamente ninguno de los
estudios que se sacan tiene la más mínima
utilidad para los ganaderos ¡Pensadlo bien!
Si tenéis una explotación de cabras ¿Qué
tipo de investigación necesitáis?
Querréis saber cómo podéis producir más
y mejor leche ¿Verdad?
Estudios sobre cómo alimentar mejor a los
animales, suplementos dietéticos o incluso
ingeniería genética.
Pues bien, si entráis en la web del ICIA,
por ejemplo, que es el Instituto Canario de
Investigaciones Agrícolas, no vais a encontrar
nada por el estilo.
Ahora bien, hay montones de artículos académicos
que te explican el origen racial de la cabra
palmera, si está emparentada con otras cabras
de Marruecos o de Tanzania o si existían
durante la edad media ¿Utilidad práctica?
Prácticamente cero.
Mientras tanto, según el ranking que saca
el TIMES HIGHER EDUCATION, los estudios de
Wageningen son los más citados en su campo.
¡Pero la cosa no se queda aquí!
¿A que no adivináis cuál es la lengua oficial
de esta universidad?
Seguramente pensaréis que, estando en Holanda,
hablarán en holandés ¿Verdad?
¡Pues nada de eso!
Hablamos de la capital mundial de la investigación
agrícola ¡Pero no sólo eso!
El número de estudiantes extranjeros en las
universidades técnicas holandeses bate un
nuevo record
En esta universidad, más del 40% de los estudiantes
son extranjeros.
Y lo mismo ocurre con el personal investigador.
No importante de dónde seas.
Si tienes talento para la agricultura, tienes
tu sitio en Wageningen.
Y por eso, la lengua oficial es el inglés.
Eso explica que Wageningen sean, por ejemplo,
los pioneros en el uso de Lámparas LED para
los invernaderos, que permiten crear microclimas
artificiales controlados al milímetro.
Gracias a esto, Países Bajos es uno de los
líderes en cultivo de tomates, pese a que,
en condiciones naturales, los tomates jamás
crecerían en un país tan frío ¡Pero no
sólo eso!
En un país como EEUU, los granjeros necesitan
unos 126 litros de agua para cultivar 1 kilo
de tomates.
Pues bien, gracias a las investigaciones de
esta universidad, ahora será posible producir
lo mismo con sólo 8 litros de agua.
Imaginad el ahorro que supone no sólo desde
el punto de vista económico sino también
ecológico.
¡Pero esperad un momento!
La investigación está muy bien pero… no
sirve de nada si se queda en la universidad.
Y en eso, Holanda también es todo un ejemplo
de cómo hacer las cosas bien.
DE LA UNIVERSIDAD AL CAMPO
Volvamos a España por un momento.
Imaginad que tenemos un huerto con tomates
y queremos invertir en esta tecnología hidropónica
que nos va a permitir ahorrar el consumo de
agua.
La Unión Europea y, más concretamente, la
Política Agraria Común, da toda clase de
subvenciones a los agricultores para modernicen
sus cultivos.
Así que nos vamos a la Agencia de Extensión
Agraria, que son las oficinas donde gestionan
estas ayudas.
Pues bien, ahí nos van a dar el dinero y
se van a asegurar de que, efectivamente, lo
vamos a gastar para mejorar nuestras técnicas
de producción.
Hasta aquí todo muy bien.
Pero ¿Cómo sabemos qué máquinas tenemos
que contratar?
Puede parecer evidente que un agricultor sabe,
mejor que nadie, lo que necesita para su cultivo.
Pero lo cierto es que el mundo agrícola evoluciona
tan rápido como las empresas de Internet.
Y si nadie nos asesora, tendremos que buscar
la información por nuestra cuenta ¡Pues
esa es la situación en la que se encuentran
casi todos los agricultores españoles!
Hay una brecha gigantesca entre la universidad
y el campo.
El caso holandés es totalmente distinto.
En este país existen las llamadas Oficinas
de Consejo Agrícola.
Es decir, que hay una persona dedicada a explicarnos
qué tipo de máquinas deberíamos comprar
y qué tecnologías se adaptan mejor para
nuestro cultivo.
¿El resultado?
El campo holandés no se parece en nada al
de ningún otro país.
Mientras España es el mayor consumidor de
antibióticos de consumo animal de toda Europa,
los ganaderos de Países Bajos ya está utilizando
las técnicas veterinarias más punteras,
de tal forma que pueden prevenir las enfermedades
antes que curarlas.
Lo mismo ocurre con los pesticidas que se
utilizan para las plantas.
En este país han descubierto que si utilizan
drones que monitorizan los cultivos, pueden
controlar todos y cada uno de los vegetales
y evitar que contraigan infecciones de ningún
tipo.
Y en un país donde, casi todos los cultivos
son de regadío, han conseguido reducir el
consumo de agua en casi un 90%.
Y las exportaciones de productos agrícolas
superaron los 92.000 millones de euros el
año pasado ¡No sólo eso!
Holanda también está ganando dinero gracias
a exportar su propia tecnología.
Emiratos Árabes Unidos usarán sistemas holandeses
para garantizar la seguridad alimentaria
Y no sólo hablamos de los Emiratos.
Ya os hemos contado aquí, en VisualPolitik,
cómo Singapur está empezando a desarrollar
granjas urbanas.
Ese proyecto lleva tecnología holandesa.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Creéis que se pueden
importar este tipo de políticas en otros
países?
¿Hasta qué punto estas tecnologías que
se desarrollan en Holanda van a permitir alimentar
al mundo entero?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.